we've been waiting for this for so long
i mean
so long
metroid dread was a rumor
when i was a kid man
oh my gosh listen to that music
yes
let's go
ah by ruined i think it's how you
pronounce it virulent
floating organism that drained energy
from its prey through physical contact
metroids were originally created by the
chozo and named after their word for
ultimate warrior their value as a
bioweapon sparked several crises and as
a result all traces of them have been
eliminated they are now extinct
all right x parasite a gelatinous
parasitic organism indigenous to the
planet sr-388 it could absorb the dna of
its host living or dead and replicate
its form when infecting a living host it
could even access the host's memories
ex-parasites were driven not by emotion
but by an instinctive need to replicate
and spread to increasingly stronger
hosts
their inability to be controlled mark
them as even more dangerous than their
sole predator the metroids like the
metroids they are believed extinct
oh got a nice little
artwork scene here okay
[Music]
uh oh
that doesn't look good
with no metroid surviving on sr 388 it
became infested with the x horrifying
parasites capable of imitating any
living being unaware of this i set foot
on the planet got infected and almost
died so this kind of recap of the story
to this point
for those who haven't played the metroid
games or played them like i don't know
two decades ago
man yes this is recapping the story to
this point the only thing that saved me
was a vaccine created from metroid dna
which also left me uniquely able to
oppose the x this ability was tested
immediately when i went to a biologic
space
laboratories research station to
investigate a distress signal
[Music]
oh
no
yeah i love the fusion suit
fusion suit so good there i battled many
powerful x forms including the sax which
was the x mimicking me in my power suit
at full strength i eventually eliminated
the x minutes on sr 388 by setting the
bsl research station on a collision
course with the planet
after that the x and metroids were just
memories or so we thought
just when it all seemed over the
galactic federation received a
mysterious video transmission
it showed an x alive and in the wild
thorough analysis proved the video was
real although the cinder was unknown the
transmission was traced to a particular
planet
and i'm guessing that's where we're
heading now by the way guys i have read
very little about the game i don't know
much about the setup or anything so all
this is is fresh new information to me
it was called zdr if the x had somehow
escaped extinction out there they would
pose a threat to the entire galaxy the
galactic federation dispatched a
research team of seven
e-m-i'm e-m-m-i to investigate
we're just gonna call those emmys right
i mean
we gotta simplify it a bit here
an emmy is a large research robot
designed to capture field samples and
extract their dna their incredible
mobility and protective plating made of
the strongest stuff in the universe
practically guaranteed the mission's
success
but not long after their arrival on zdr
all communication was lost
and that's where i come in
what is happening on cdr is the planet
really infested with x as the only one
immune to the parasites it's up to me to
go there and find out
all right here we go
we are flying in now
[Music]
a little bit less than 10 minutes
oh dude the suit looks so good
does not seem appropriate
what's that why not
why does it not seem appropriate
always the reward
okay
the atmosphere and t minus ten
um
eight
seven
six
four
three
two
one
let's do it
oh wait what the heck happened she's in
a different suit now
where's the ship
what's going on
[Music]
dude what is happening
okay here we go i'm like
so now she's gonna recap what happened
who you calling lady
oh man did they call her lady in the
previous games like is that something i
forgot about
i don't remember it but it's been so
long it is entirely possible that
it was like a not really an inside joke
sort of an inside thing you know
oh my
that does not look like a guy you want
to mess with
charge shot
he just shrugged that off like it was
nothing
missile
nothing
ice beam ice beam samus come on
uh oh
uh oh i don't think she's gonna
i don't think she's gonna make it
through this one guys
wait what
whoa
whoa what just happened
i have no idea
yep my suit's gone
dude that looks like right out of
metroid prime right there
[Music]
oh my gosh here we go
here we go dude
okay so uh it looks like you cannot use
the d-pad
it's a little bit surprising i wonder if
there's an option for that
not that i i care i don't really mind
but
wait they don't really give you any uh
no they're like there's like no control
options really
tutorials
okay
all right yeah so uh b jumps
oh my goodness she has like a melee
are you kidding me that's uh x
and then why to shoot
[Music]
charge shot do we have charge shot no
okay that is uh l1
like some sort of targeting
give me a laser sight here it's pretty
cool
wait is that for the uh
oh missiles
oh i just used four of them i only have
15 total oh well
hopefully we don't have to uh
there we go got some energy from that
okay there's got to be a way
that i can like aim
at an angle without running right
because like right now if i if i try to
aim this way she just keeps running
oh that's probably what this is for yeah
there we go that that locks you in place
okay perfect
when tilting
wait what press zl to slide
oh what
yeah here we go
free aim
is that what i'm supposed to be shooting
oh right there okay
looks like that's gonna require charge
shot or something oh goodness
i saw that thing but just a second too
late
dude i can already tell the control in
this game
is going to be insane
like this is going gonna set up for so
many unique
control moments
and i'm sure it's only i mean i mean as
you get power ups i'm sure it's just
gonna get even more insane what is this
thing right here
map station oh refill the missiles
perfect since i
just wasted four for no reason okay i
don't think i can get
into there yet because i don't think i
can
yeah i have to slide and that one's not
quite on the ground i love how she like
grabs onto the edge like that that is
really cool see if i can shoot from that
angle though
oh wait come on
oh you can yeah it's nice
all right so
hold our to ready missiles and press y
to fire there we go
it's gonna take a little getting used to
the uh
sliding like that
and what do we have here
she doesn't seem concerned at all about
access like
what did that to her earlier yes i have
reviewed your vital signs and video a
lot from the data you uploaded oh okay
yeah what happened tell me adam what
happened to me
but i cannot account for water oh great
consciousness great appreciate the help
dramatic physical changes in you
yep whatever caused these changes seems
to have stripped you of most abilities
you might call it physically i'm shocked
i tell you i'm just shocked i can't
believe we've lost our abilities
i can't believe it federation database
against your video law it appears to
have been a chosen proposal the
attacker's identity is not yet clear
why would the chozo be attacking us in
the depths of cpr your top priority
should be to return to your ship on the
surface this situation is precarious
trust your instincts as you navigate
upward
all right trust instincts navigate
upward consist of multiple areas
shuttles elevators and other modes of
transport connect them keep an eye out
for ways to reach the surface
okay shuttles elevators other modes of
transportation the ship's location is
marked on your global map check it for
yourself okay
you may encounter pockets of low
temperature your metroid dna renders you
vulnerable to such environments spending
time in areas will be harmful to you
okay can't go into the cold area there
are many such cold areas scattered
underground do not enter them your basic
power scene okay final thing
underground interference is preventing
radio check in with me in any network
station should you find okay gotcha
gotcha gotcha
gotcha gotcha yeah might as well go
ahead and save right
oh dude just save animation so slick
okay press plus to open the map minus to
open up options all right here we go
adjust brightness system
oh yeah they do have controls i was like
that would be crazy if they
and it is pretty much just here's how
you do it there's no
there is no uh
dude i can't get over this melee though
oh my goodness you could do like when
you're doing a sliding melee she does
this little kick
okay that's options and then the map is
here
perfect so that marks the uh the ammo
recharge station which i'm guessing you
know you can use multiple times
all right so i don't think we can oh
wait i can open these now
maybe it's slightly different than the
other one
oh yeah this one's slightly different
[Music]
oh my goodness
that is a very large enemy
uh whoa wait what is this use a melee
counter at the right moment to parry
certain attacks and automatically take
aim at the attacker press x to use your
melee counter now
oh my goodness dude that is insane
parry enemy attacks with a melee counter
by pressing x at the right dude i'm sure
this has been known for like months but
like i said i really didn't want to know
i kind of went in very blind okay
apparently we have the wall jump right
off the bat don't have to worry about
unlocking that or anything
where'd that thing go defeating an enemy
that has been stunned as a result of a
counter will cause it to drop more items
oh interesting
dude
that is sick
i don't know if i can kill this thing
without countering it or not
what is that guy right there
can't fight him i guess
come on come down here and attack me
attack me i want to do the counter again
oh it's so slick dude
it is so slick
oh whoops
i didn't know if i was gonna be able to
beat that guy or not in time
seriously like
i can't believe i'm playing this
it's almost like i'm playing something
that is like
it's like fan made it's like it's not a
real it's not really happening
we've been wanting and begging for so
long
for a new metroid game and now it's
finally here man
press x while running to execute a
powerful dash melee unlike other melee
counters the dash melee will damage the
enemy
wait press x while running
oh so if you're running and you're able
to melee like that
it'll actually damage the enemy that's
pretty cool
gonna have to see if we can hit one of
those
uh is there any way i can get up here
i don't think so
gotta slide through
okay wait why did this pop up there we
go if an area in the on the map is
blinking it indicates that a hidden item
is there
uh all right so what's blinking oh this
whole little section okay
yep i see it too
nice
oh but now i can't get back over there
can i
missile tank acquired missile capacity
increased by two
whoa
hello
hello
is anyone here
oh no it's going to be one of those emmy
things isn't it yes there it is
no
oh dude something has clearly
been
tampering with that thing
okay am i dead an emmy's attack can be
counted by pressing x the exact moment
of the flash however the timing is
extremely difficult to gauge
making this a desperate maneuver
okay wait and press zl to slide under
the emmy
get out of here
i don't have the controls mastered yet
i'm freaking out i gotta get away from
this thing
yeah i'm not gonna sit there and try to
fight it
kidding me
he said it's indestructible
dude what is this am i getting ice beam
already
ice beam within like the first half hour
of the game
let's go
oh
wait is it actually the ice beam
no the energy from the central unit
transformed the arm cannon into an omega
cannon
omega blaster online
hold l to use aim mode tilt to aim if a
target is nearby samus will
automatically face that direction okay
once wait wait wait hold r
i don't have to hold r
press y while standing
still holding r to fire aim at the core
oh wait so you can't charge it unless
you're doing this right here interesting
okay
wait is the thing gone
no it's not gone it's still right there
oh no
wait i got a whole are don't i
come on
come on come up there i dare dairy
aim at the core
oh i can't see though
i'm aiming that way
okay i'm not sure that's what i'm
supposed to do
it's gotta be though right
oh i can't climb up there because this
one is like
oh dude did that take it out
i have to shoot it right in the eye huh
and it just vanished
it's not creepy at all omega cannon
depleted oh no reverting to regular arm
cannon
oh dang see i was like oh i thought
these things were going to be really
hard to kill the whole game but no now
i've just got this and i can't go back
and recharge it so i guess it's like a
uh
it sort of expires after you use it for
its intended purpose so now yeah it just
goes back to the regular
all right well at least we got rid of
that one so we don't worry about that
one bothering us
come on crouch
yeah i'll take another missile okay
let's take a look at the map here
okay we're right here
let's see what the mission log yeah we
destroyed an emmy
zero one p received the atom briefing
oh yeah so it tells me i'm supposed to
be working my way upwards right that's
what we need to be focusing on right now
have i already been in here i'm pretty
sure i've been here right yeah this is
how i got up here all this
okay so now this is the area that i
couldn't get to before
whoa
save station
fully restore health maybe yep let's go
definitely want to take advantage of
that
hey wait where's the music
come on where's the the classic metroid
music when i save
maybe it'll happen after we make it
through the first little area here
okay that floods that out
now can we go through here
oh no wait she can't get back through
there now we gotta go this way
[Music]
dude i love how it's like
all the cutscenes i'm i'm surprised by
this
that's obviously something very
different from the old
2d metroids you just did not see a lot
of that
if any i'm trying to remember if there
was any and i don't think there were any
infusion
and if there weren't any infusion there
definitely weren't any in the others
okay let's see here
i'm not sure why the
map popped up automatically for me right
there
is there something specifically that
they're wanting me to see
these blue things i don't know
okay wait what does this blue do
yeah i'm just gonna go down this way
oh wait this is cold am i gonna get hurt
down there
remember it said that i can't go into
cold areas
see if i start taking damage
no
no but it definitely does look like it's
a colder area down there
i don't think i can get up there any
higher
oh no another one
all right we gotta find one of those
areas to charge up
okay and this one does not look uh
injured like the other one
the other one looked like it had taken a
lot of recent damage okay come on samus
you should get the idea by now the only
way we're gonna be able to attack these
things is with the uh
omega cannon
oh no
it's following me over there what is
that do i need to go that way no i don't
think so
yes get in here please just run just run
just run
no
oh no
no it's gonna kill me
deflect it
can i go through here oh yes i can
is it gone now
i have no idea dude
i have no idea if it's still there or
not oh but here's another little upgrade
right here
missile tank yes increase dude we're
already at 19. let's go
can i get through here oh wait you can
they what
what
oh as soon as you get in there it shuts
oh another save station
where's this map
uploading data
oh adam's going to talk to us again
we're clearly trying to capture you they
may have been back if so
at least you're just trying to capture
me and not kill me that's good
at least for now right it's reasonable
to assume all emmy will be hostile and
now the calls can detect vibrations in
the air within a certain range
essentially they can hear you okay on
detecting vibrations an enemy enters
surveillance multitrack
stay out of line of sight line of sight
when this happens otherwise the danger
to an enemy that has seen you will begin
pursuing part of the pursuit protocol is
to seal them easily exits who could be
trapped inside to survive you must leave
its range of pursuit debate the enemy
and it will disengage this will also
unseal the exits okay so just get away
for long enough at least it's assigned
so their control system must permit them
to operate only within that range
i estimate a 99 probability
you said capture why why'd you wait till
now
to tell me about death
estimated 99 probability of death if an
enemy captures you okay then be a very
small opportunity to escape but
exploiting this window will be virtually
impossible the enemy are immune to your
current weapons you lack the unique
energy used to defeat the first enemy
your only option now is to evade capture
at your heights
should be simply just you yep gotcha
gotcha just survive and get out
save your progress yep let's do it
okay so now
let's see here we got a couple different
ways we could go
go back there wait what oh no i i
stepped on the same thing it's like what
is happening all right let's take a look
at the map here that's the way we came
that doesn't open
wait what is this thing right here
okay nothing we can do right now it
seems
all right so let's head this way
right is there any way to crawl in here
i wonder
nope doesn't seem like it at least not
right now
it's gonna have to be something that we
gain later on potentially
i feel like this is an emmy zone i don't
know why
oh wait what is this thing oh wait
that's the one of the missile
oh that one refills energy perfect
okay
remember he said we're supposed to be
trying to move up
but i'm still just like my curiosity's
getting the best of me here
okay i think we've already been through
this area
no
oh this is where i just was earlier
this is where i just was
okay well all right we got to think
about this then
all right so if we go
this way it looks like we could keep
heading
to the west
or to the left side
uh let's see
here all right there's no way for me to
go like i have to go back to the left
don't i
i don't think there's any way for me to
to get through right there
you're just gonna be waiting for me
yeah see that's why i said i was like i
got a feeling this is an emmy zone
oh no he's just right there
oh that stinks
oh i didn't get away that came over
oh i thought i timed it right darn it
looks like i got it a couple of times
but
uh countering emmy's attack to send it
for a moment yeah that's
okay so it puts me back right here
yeah so i really want to get
just going to be up
no
dude i don't even know what i'm looking
at now for the timing am i looking for
the i or
you only have one chance oh i needed to
read that you only have one chance to
escape okay so there's like
i was thinking oh i have to press it
twice now i really need to get in here
though and it's just waiting there
okay let's take a look at the map really
quick we just need to keep going this
way
oh no dude
oh my goodness
oh i can't i can't fit through there i
can't do anything
where'd it go
wait what is there nowhere for me to go
here
this is not good
oh it's right there when the eye opens i
think
is when you have to hit it
oh my goodness it's gonna be interesting
okay but you have one chance to escape
however the timing is extremely
difficult okay so i just got lucky that
first time or the second time like the
first time i think they kind of give it
to you for free but then the time after
that i did get it i think i must have
just
gotten really lucky like i feel like
this is the way we have to go
although you know what we could like go
back down
let's see here
yeah i feel like we've got to get over
in this area
you know what i could do let's head back
this way
seriously though absolutely nothing over
there all right
oh there he is
dude where are we supposed to go
that just takes you back over here no
okay that leads in here
go this way this time go down
nothing you can do there
this is good anyway because this is this
is really helping me to get familiar
with these things and
how you have to deal with them
oh dude
like that's all that does for me that
doesn't do anything else
oh what oh my goodness
what is this how do we get down there
it was like a secret
oh no how did it get over there
that makes no sense
oh oh my goodness that was slick dude
okay remember it said my priority should
just be to escape the area okay i think
we finally escaped the area
oh goodness those little things actually
hurt me no way
yeah blast a missile with that
guy are you for real
these things are actually hurting me
oh wait i need to try to get this over
here though
let's see let's jump up can i not grab
that oh but we can't we need more ball
bad i think that's how we're going to be
able to get through
like to grab onto the ledge and then to
fit through a small area i think we're
going to have to get more ball
yep definitely gonna save
all right continue oh goodness i went
too far oh is that an energy tank
upgrade right there
oh but i can't get that either
okay can we actually get over here and
get that i don't think so
oh come on let me over there
i'm gonna try it one more time
need like a double jump or something to
be able to
slide through there
okay nothing there
back into the water we
go still trying to get used to having to
drop down to shoot those blobs because
they look so huge but then when you
start firing your gun
just not uh
they're just a little bit too short
yeah i'm not messing with these things
this time
there we go oh yeah we need to drain
some water from here
there we go
all right so i wonder should i go oh i
can't go this way
oh man so we gotta go we gotta backtrack
again
a little bit here
then we should be able to get into that
other area yeah this right here
oh nice
more fall please let's go
it's got to be the morph ball right
it's got to be the morph ball that's
what's uh
all around this area it's like we can't
get to certain spots because we need to
be able to shrink
nope this is just uh oh this is the map
downloading the map
save your progress yeah why not i'm just
gonna just out of habit and i think it
refills
yeah it reseals everything
yellow okay on the map the yellow rooms
are saving facilities the purple rooms
contain transportation devices
all right do we have any that are purple
so far
these are purple but i don't think
that's what it's referring to
all right let's take a look we remember
we need to keep trying to head for the
surface
but wait hold on when we drain that
water
did that change the stuff out here too i
think it did
yeah because now we can get over here
oh what is that thing
oh no not another emmy
oh wait this is the same in me isn't it
oh wait what is that
i have no idea what that door was
it was clearly doing something when i
was hitting it though
oh
missile took that guy out
no if it was right there
oh i missed the timing
darn it
oh
knowing where the exits are located will
dramatically increase your odds of
survival
all right so let's let's kind of regroup
here
this area no i haven't been here before
then
so all this is new it just looks very
similar to the one
before it
okay yeah we know the emmy's gonna come
after us again
let's see should i drop down i don't
think i want to drop down i think i want
to try and stay
dude we gotta do something with that
door
i don't know what it is
oh he's right there again
oh
darn it
i think it is with the first flash
because there's like a flash
sort of at the beginning when he like
does something with the the claw
and then there's another flash with the
eye but i think you have to get it on
the first flash
okay so nothing up that way
and we're just gonna jump right by him
there
oh wait what is this
oh
oh this is big
no
oh but now i can go here
oh man he's still gonna be after me
though
no sir
okay fine we'll just go this way
all right i think we're away from him
now
come on morph ball
energy already maximum oh man who's
gonna give me the more fall
looks like another missile up there i
don't know that there's anything i can
do
to get up there
currently in my current state
and i don't think there's anything i can
do to get in there right now
dude i love the call back to the
original metroid man so good
those enemies just look so similar
all right so what do we got here this
opens up this little area
missile yep
oh my gosh dude that is so fun
that is so fun to use that melee counter
oh goodness
dropped right on top of that guy
oh
yes here we go dude
oh charge me i thought it was for sure
gonna be the uh morph ball
and there's the music
[Music]
okay charge beam focus is beam energy to
unleash a powerful shot press and hold y
to charge and then release to fire
charge shots damage enemies immune to
normal beam shots such as robots and
bosses wait does that mean the enemy
robots too uh they can also open charge
beam doors in addition
samus can perform a charge attack spin
by jumping when the beam is fully
charged okay that's that's interesting
wait fully charge it
oh kind of like a little
little version of the screw attack there
oh that is so slick i like that
now let's see if i charge it oh it still
doesn't get
oh and i better have to use the charge
beam on that door remember that door we
were talking about
oh wait do you have to wait for this guy
to
do that is so awesome that you attack
him when you're
uh if you get the kind of the running
okay got that guy all right i need to
consult the map again
i mean we could uh see this is what
happens in metroid games man i get so
tempted like i want to see what's over
here now
oh it's too cold
i'm about to die
oh my gosh it kills you fast
it kills you fast
wow that death animation though
oh my goodness the suit just completely
shattering
i didn't think it would go that fast i
was like i got a little time i just want
to take a peek here maybe if i get to
the next room
the next room won't be so cold nope
nope it is very cold
oh dude you can do it while you're
while you're in midair i love it
okay so maybe that's why they actually
don't want you to
go in this direction
because let's see if i go right here i
think this is the room yeah you're
immediately in the cold room
and let's see is that noted on the map
yeah it's like this uh
it's kind of that navy blue dark blue
area right over there
okay can i use charge beam for anything
in here
i don't believe so
all right now this way this is gonna
take me back towards that emmy right
oh wait no we can't get through there
darn it man
this is the guy that refills us on our
energy might as well right might as well
top off
yeah i don't think there's any way i can
i can get up there
okay hold on so where are we supposed to
go then
we've got to get back to that spot where
the emmy is then i guess
oh i've got a charge shot this one
whoa
not too bad a couple charge shots
took him out fairly quickly
oh i feel a sneeze coming
oh excuse me okay
see do i have to charge shot
no that one was not a charge shot
see crouch down and then oh get the
angle just right
go ahead and take that guy out oh is
that an energy tank yes let's go
energy capacity increased by 100.
man remember we already saw one other
energy tank but it was in a spot where
we couldn't get to it
fired a missile at him too just curious
i feel like i should be using missiles
more because they are they are dropping
like all over the place
oh dude that's so good
you can do it when you're
when you're in mid-air like that i love
it
all right let's take out this guy
okay i feel like actually right now
we're making some pretty steady progress
towards
uh getting up getting closer to the oh
no we're not because we're already so
far down we got to get to the surface we
got to get out of here
yes i will take that energy thank you
very much
okay wait hold on
before i go in there because i know
that's an emmy area
see where this okay wait i've already
been here for sure
let's just go ahead and save now that we
got the charge shot
go ahead and top off everything
okay hold on now hold on hold on a
second
i'm trying to remember where that
okay that says central unit right there
is that that kind of weird oh that's a
charge being door
which i have not been through yet
right here i've not been through this
door
oh but man i can't even reach it
let's see
oh
i've got to get to that spot where the
emmy was chasing me and i got to that
door that we would shoot it a couple of
times and then
nothing really happened but you could
kind of see like a meter filling up
dude what is this room
already been here no or yeah i have
oh great
dude you barely move and he is after you
oh no
i do want to see if you
okay yeah chart shot does nothing
no
do wait i am so confused you have to hit
it twice
you have one chance to escape
man because i i feel like i am hitting
the timing right on it but
and clearly this is the way i'm supposed
to go because you get the little
cutscene
yeah yeah we know the emmy's coming
we already know
i wonder if you can make it over there i
don't think so
no dude
no i'm trying to jump up there thank you
nope actually that's bad that's really
bad
that's really bad
no i don't want to jump on top of the
thing
just trying to jump over him
oh hold on
what the heck was that
i feel like we gotta
okay never mind
must need like a dash or something to
get
on those doors that automatically close
when you head their way
oh this is another one of these
or is this the one i was already at i'm
so i'm so bad with directions guys it's
not even funny regulars of the channel
already know that but
for any newcomers out there yeah it's
really bad
both in video games and in life man just
not not so good with directions okay
we're now officially over 20 on the
missiles
yeah there's there's a couple spots that
we need to explore right now though
oh goodness i didn't see that one right
there
oh look at this can destroy all that
oh i went too early
i have a feeling
really i thought for sure missile or
charge shot was going to be able to
destroy that area right there
yeah dude i kind of don't want to press
too far over here
sensor lock door wait i wonder if that's
the door that i
was thinking about
with the emmy
whoa this is awesome
i kind of want to go back but then oh
get out of there that one's too hot
oh too hot again
oh this guy's the timing's a little
different on him
okay which way do we want to go i think
the yellow rooms are
yeah it's like they're the safe rooms
right
another save room okay
pretty sure eventually we'll get the
ability to be able to like fast travel
between different locations
should be handy right now but
not the end of the world we need to
explore anyway we need to
even though i'm not good with directions
i need to try my best to figure it out
get a good lay of the land
anything we can do here doesn't look
like it
oh what is this thing
what is this thing
the thermal fuels flow has been
redirected
always is that gonna make all those
areas that were really hot a second ago
now it's
hopefully it's draining it
oh those doors open up now
so weird how like those little things
are just like growing in the
right in the middle
oh goodness i can't get these guys
they're wrecking me right now
all right
oh it did open all of them
wait this is where i just was
yeah now let's see if that same area
that was hot a second ago
it is okay that didn't do anything
oh man i'm messing up the timing
yeah this is the hot area too
okay i kind of wanted to travel back
this way anyway because i really do want
to find that
that door
is this a new one or is he gonna have
something more to say this time
uploading data
there was no record of your assailant in
the federation database however there
are records of the ozone warrior tribe
there is a strong possibility that you
are connected you have seen the warrior
tribes architecture and artifacts on
this planet i conclude that this was one
of their settlements
but why would someone lead you here and
send the emmy after you
the footage of the ex-parasite may have
been staged to lure you in
interesting remains unclear
but your priority hasn't changed you
must return to the [ __ ]
yeah somewhere
my system that has restored power to the
closed
doors oh the just rosie gotcha just
restored those thermal doors to search
for the unique energy you employed
against the first enemy it is the only
way you can confront them
unfortunately this energy is limited
you may have noticed it disappearing
after an emmy is destroyed
there are six remaining enemies hunting
you you have no means to confront them
remember that
six emmy still after us we have no means
to confront them
all right we will do our best to
remember that and thank you very much
okay so these are the types of doors
that are now
open to us
i think this is the missile one right oh
no energy all right hey we'll take
we'll top off the energy there
okay now we've got to find that door
let's see where was it it was called no
not an emmy zone door
i think it's that one yeah
i think it's a sensor lock door
but how do i get over there
drop drop drop
okay now yeah
yeah yeah this is it this is it
come on get up there
nope this is not it this is not hit
oh it's this guy again
okay hold on where did it say
okay sensor lock door this way
sensor lock door dude it's probably just
okay it's that one
so that is the sensor lock door well at
least now we know right
dude this guy got fast all of a sudden
so the sensor locked doors are the ones
that shut automatically when you get too
close okay so there's another type of
door power beam door power beam door
wait what did that say right in here
open thermal door
so the thermal doors are what we just
got a question mark right there
the thermal doors are what we just
figured out how to open earlier so
there's nothing i could do now right
here i can't get back
yeah i'm not gonna be able to get back
so the only way is to go this way
and i can't go through that way because
i don't know how to open the sensor lock
doors yet
yep another sensor lock
don't need to talk to adam again
but do we need to go there's a missile
tank
yeah we can't get through there right
now as far as i know
as far as i know there's nothing we can
do there
so yeah i really think it it really
wants us to go through the thermal door
go that way
there he is
i'm just gonna stop trying to find that
other door right now
no
dude he's still after me
oh
cut scene let's go
i guess we're going the right way
oh no is this our first boss it is let's
go dude
oh no
i'm like using up all my missiles
oh goodness
it's weird this guy is like not doing
anything
can i actually destroy the gun that'd be
kind of cool if you could
oh goodness
[Music]
oh wow
okay out of missiles
all right you got about enough time for
one full charge shot between there we go
we got him
we got him
and that is a very large eyeball
oh we're gonna absorb the power though
let's go
and the emmy is fast
approaching uh-oh uh-oh
let's take it out let's take it out the
energy from the central unit
transformed the arm cannon into an omega
cannon
omega blaster online
gonna come there
okay that's not what i'm supposed to do
with it
uh
wait
yeah it's what i thought
and heat up the shielding
hold why
i'm so confused dude
oh
dude you can all this is crazy
it is crazy how much you can do with
this omega thing
once you have it
but then suddenly after you destroy the
emmy it's like okay i'm done now i have
no more power
well there he is here he's here he's
going this way
blast him no i miss
dude do i have to fight the boss again
what if i do what if i have to fight the
boss again it wasn't too hard but still
yeah okay picks up right here
yeah so then you switch over to this one
so i gotta have enough to be able to
fully charge that so i've got to get
i've got to put a good amount of
distance between me and the emmy
he's up here again yep there he is drop
down oh my gosh samus
oh wait no cancel i want to continue not
quit
i still got to figure out the timing
like
oh i don't know if you're supposed to
wait or if you're supposed to push it
all right
now we don't have to try to fight it
right there like we could
could drop a little bit like see
okay come on after me oh i should have
went up top
there was a lot more room there but
there's gonna be plenty of room here
if i do this right here
what
why did it not
huh
oh wait i've got to use the knowledge
that i've just gained you guys
i think i have to do this right here
to get that little uh protective
shielding off of it
oh my goodness
it's like they were giving me all the
clues right there
giving me all the clues
i'm gonna jump right here
yeah come this way buddy
all right so i clearly don't have enough
room if i go that way so i've got a
that was definitely like heating up you
could see that it was
i was starting to turn red so
and then this takes a good like what a
full three seconds if not more
to fully charge up
yeah drop down here
oh no
are you kidding me
no i was too close
i was too close
i was hoping it would like stun him for
a little bit longer that would still
give me enough time to fully charge the
uh
not so much
about four or five seconds
yeah so this time what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna i'm gonna put a few shots on
him on that first little ledge like
right here
yeah drop down here drop down drop down
drop down more
[Music]
oh let's go
right in the face dude
that's so cool man
all right so it's that we have six of
those after us so that's
five now
or did we start with six and four now i
think it's probably five
oh wait what did i just absorb some
power from that thing
[Music]
spider magnet acquired what the heck
spider magnet allows samus to attach to
blue
magnetic surface walls and ceiling using
a magnetic field
tilt left stick in the direction of
certain walls and ceilings to grab on
samus can move and attack while in this
state hold up while attached to a
ceiling to press against it oh this is
awesome
dude this is awesome and this is just
like the first what hour or so of the
game crazy omega canada depleted and
offline yeah surprise surprise
surprise surprise you're going to take
it away from me
oh so you could probably like
lead him in here and fight too if you
wanted oh yeah this would be a great
room to battle him in
you'd have a lot of room right here if
you ran all this way
i did see that blue stuff back there but
i just kind of want to see what's over
here
too oh dude this is awesome so you can
just like
so if you press down she just falls off
you can aim at any angle oh that's nice
whoa
so now can we do
this didn't go in here
oh no not another one of these things
oh i'm out of missiles that's right
there we go give me those missiles
yeah i keep forgetting about this move
right here
i need to remember this because you can
just like
charge it up and just jump into guys
yeah i thought that one looked like it
was gonna be a little bit more
powerful
or a little bit stronger okay wait can
we do this right here
yes we can
missile tank acquired
all right it's up to 23 missiles
nicely done
dude this area looks so cool
oh wait what is this
something tells me we cannot take this
thing on yet
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
do that again do that again
oh it popped up with a a uh deflect
thing
oh my gosh that is so awesome
that is so awesome man i love it
oh i love it so much what a great little
addition
it's so crazy i feel like i'm just
randomly like guessing which way to go
and yet somehow i'm apparently going the
right way
because i i keep kind of progressing and
getting to new cut scenes and uh
apparently we're about to have a second
boss here okay
oh my goodness that is very large
whoa
oh no
oh you gotta hit him right in the head
i don't know if there's anything i can
do right there if i just wait
oh man
oh wait wait wait and
go now
let's go
yeah give me some more missiles
oh he's just mad now he's not beaten yet
he's just very angry at this point oh
what the heck
what am i supposed to do here
that's is that his weak point now
i think it is
it's turning red yeah yeah yeah
definitely a weak point
oh hit it with a charge shot
still in this
oh no
that is ugly
i have no idea we're supposed to do
oh wait right here
i still have no idea what we're supposed
to do
wait dude i'm so lost
okay wait hold on
i gotta get by him somehow
oh we can slide up under him
oh that's not even fair
no
no dude that was such an awesome boss
fight
was such an awesome boss fight
like multiple phases
oh i bet i was close to the end too
yeah i i missed the little uh there was
a moment where you could parry and i
missed it
yeah i got to get better at the parry
yeah give me all that energy i think
he's right in here isn't he
yeah we'll just can we skip the cut
scene this time yes we can
ouch
yeah so your regular missiles do nothing
or your regular charge shot
or no your regular just like beam
i can't think of the right thing your
charge shot absolutely
oh goodness come on
and missiles
do good damage
there we go
now's when he's gonna go invis
oh did i hit him right there
oh i missed
yeah that one you can still damage with
just your regular shots
okay come on that should give me some
health right
i saw it pop up on screen you better
give it to me
i was at 49 let's see if it gives me any
health off that
oh see that was the clue like i was too
grossed out
i missed it
again get up here
no i'm trying to move
no i went the wrong way
[Music]
that's not where i meant to go yeah dude
i got to hit that uh it's obviously it's
not a must i think there's still a way
for you to um
know what that's interesting right there
no attack is unavoidable i actually love
that more games
need to do that
oh it's so awesome see like right there
that is just major damage perfect if you
if you get it the first time on that guy
like it's just instantly he's done all
right again
we go again
see like i can't get hit by that that's
such an easy one to dodge
so
no dude there's nowhere for me to go
come on
oh i'm doing terrible this time
i'm doing terrible
let's go let's go that was quick
oh dude you can do missiles this whole
time too
let's go
oh i thought i was gonna hit that
oh i'm out i'm out no
i gotta just use charge shot
jump over him please yes let's go
come on hit that yes give me missiles
all right perfect
oh see that's that's ridiculous that you
can't just jump over him like that right
there
that his tail hurts you come on i'm
samus i'm in a metal protective suit
oh no he's doing that one now
jump over him yes let's go
yes that's the one i wanted if you
destroy this right here right now
nope
uh hello
oh no
let's go dude oh yes i'm hitting you
with 23 missiles coming up man
can you survive this can you survive 23
missiles let's see
no you cannot
no you cannot let's go finally dude
what an epic boss fight though for real
man
wait is he not done
is he not done
oh that's so sick i gotta take a
screenshot i gotta take a screenshot
right there
another screenshot let's go
wow man
i can't believe this is all like so
early in the game that the fights are
already this good
the boss fights are already this good
man are you serious right now